now you guys are stand-up comics Brian
we know we know you're here and you know
I'm a stand-up comic you can't you know
come on try to follow me a few times
hey hey Jason Jason don't because
there's honest in this car they call me
the machine gun weena don't call you
that let me see the gun never heard that
never heard it the people could you talk
too fast and we can't understand your
bits that's how what it is oh you know
what this is Pryor 1000 Mod cast yeah
hello young yes a million dollars call
me when you're serious about that you
didn't answer it
hey you know you didn't slide that over
who I just saw myself on sex immediately
I was really six I hated myself but how
long ago was that would you plan sex in
the city abuela waiter you're the rabbit
right a cyclist yeah it's late Howie
Hornstein the rabs guy who has a
one-night stand with Carrie I give her a
sex sprain and then she blows me off and
I'm really sensitive so they look at you
and you were 36 at the top I was 36 and
I just that was 1997 this is what Jude
Law was a [ __ ] right so you're trying to
add that's right Judy that's a
compliment he was sexy and he had a
receipt again I'll worry hey he was the
man though you used your hair by those
get like nine moves in one year you
think I think so here's why
yeah yes I don't get mad I live here too
like my hair so annoying during this
quarantine by the way it just keeps my
pouring out of my head but your hair now
it looks like it this is on purpose like
okay like the way you had it before
where you were trying to do a style yeah
man it was I knew what you were trying
to do I know it was you were going for
this but no I'm being honest because it
now this is where you need to be because
now it's like you're it's almost like
you're you're preparing for what's next
to come yes it's a good head and you're
doing it gracefully you're doing a shot
card do a Sean Connery do it Jason say
yes and go
- what's happening gracefully I don't
want to say balding because that's mean
but and I'm and I'm thick now I'm thick
if you see my the last Instagram post I
posted against Chris Oh with the white
you see what you see how menacing I look
with two knives to them there it is
I think Swartz Annette a really good
neck isn't my drama I'm all trapped you
know what you look like then that pic
you look up go cholo in that pic you
have you look like an L a very strange
you can see I'm the great singers Tiger
King oh that dude is amazing it wasn't
his voice obviously I was like man but
then I [ __ ] and then then we found a
nice song know what I think about I
think about the Comedy Store like back
in the day like when it was actually
empty you remember like back then and
one of my view doesn't remember that it
was so it was so empty all the time my
favorites though where the late-night
sets when no one's there I'm Brian
you teaching in front of seven people
and then me and like the Lea and Jay and
people in the back row or the comics
said like 1 a.m. on a Tuesday teaching
Brian Callens dance class just doing
ballet in front of 7 people as a grown
man people enjoy it
I did that for years I I get 30 minutes
for an Israeli guy who is like one guy
one guy at home the morning he was like
this I'm just [ __ ] killing with one
guy I just met a very good though
oh I was committing to every joke dude
that's minute by being something and
then I want to see if Brian quality you
know problem no no
oh sorry on your Instagram you did I
can't stand moving I can't lower sir
like feel it you can't yeah
I can't stay on the right side my window
I can't stand the wrong
it's bad it's so bad
hold on okay I can't stand the rain oh
if these are glasses no we're doing with
your body
ah yeah yeah that's what that you know
what that is that's right
drinking and judging you can't do it
without moving feel like this I can't
stand the rain sign my window z-pak
can't stand the ring that my wind over
usually white guys have to do something
else something else try to sing yeah
ready yeah girl I'm in love with you
honeymoon honeymoon that's the in statue
of a John Legend have a great voice and
soul tried to come out there and then I
went bad so if I really if I start
warming it up can see like classic rock
that's more oh yeah miss me chills Judy
you're high for me
really it's what a great song still high
for me last year of college for us still
[Laughter]
if you can do it I can do it do do it
don't worry about hurting Bryan's
feeling Portuguese by the way him yep
yes yep
Steve Perry's Portuguese Merliah raised
by mostly women I think Tim what's that
yeah he had an interesting childhood are
you alright seeing this to a girl
can you imagine without here's the best
way to describe in my opinion great art
and it's not me I'm a steel every
scissors no but but one of the would you
say emotional when you hear great music
now when you see an amazing movie when
you when you see like a [ __ ] painting
that just even greats taalib even great
sanap think what happens what happened
no no no I thought we wildly say thank
thank you
super-annoying that that's really [ __ ]
yeah didn't know I said okay well it was
in my head I said okay I came out thank
you you know if I may mm-hmm so if you
were even great standard yeah right and
that's how neat she described the only
[ __ ] way to get out of this cycle of
being a human being [ __ ] sleeping
eating you know that requires is art
yeah it steps you out of it that's the
value of money well haven't you saw it
you know what sometimes it goes sockless
I'll tell you why I bought these they're
very expensive now I have you keep
saying that they're very expensive what
are they going goosal my feet 600 600
miles so I have to wear them because I
won't get my my like winner without
sometimes we make those widows that's
how you become like that become you'd
get the [ __ ] I'm sorry that's the angry
dad of me you're paying $600 of those I
did but I bought two others
those are 380 Dave look there's used um
used somebody more like that 15 I'm a
Nike guy I'm but I don't like those I
thought first for a minute though very
very old game crest but apparently
they're but whole new look wait what
kind what are they called golden goose
okay I just want to make sure to
remember what never ever to buy but I
got it now but we'll see what happened
what's what's that about you play just
some guy with a moustache what do you
play no they won't let me have this no I
don't know if I could say a lot
it's got Oliver Hudson a Malin Akerman
in it and me don't make me angry
don't make me angry with its top secret
because I just don't know what I could
say I don't know anything I don't really
give our parading czar great but you
know what when are we all gonna be back
parading
stuff today I'm done with mine could be
the whiskey English Japanese is great so
that's crazy
do you see the the mayor of New York
said it it's Lal now it's law now you
got to wear masks outside they're
starting that in LA - we're in New York
New York I mean III will understand
doing it in I wear a mask when I go into
stores in LA I get that but if I'm
outside on the sidewalk keeping my
distance I think that's 200 would you
want me to look up I'm gonna start off
with we all know a little game where a
little game a little game that be Kris
oh yeah I believe that he's holding that
chris has always been a fighter he looks
like when he screams yeah that's how he
was how would I know he was that stuff
in house I look yeah well that's um by
the way Joe brother his brother the
governor of he was well to say more than
him um [ __ ] huge big boys
yeah I'm Jake [ __ ] boys yeah that's
that's annoying
it's annoying yeah and I bet every bit
of six to six I'll call her you me I'm
six four
yeah oh that's funny she's probably
doing as a joke okay
all right Brian we're sorry we just make
a little so comedy got some babies
welcome back to Brian's baby touching
comedy club I heard about this guy - all
right fellas okay you coming down man
even these crow novelists keep doing
this when we do we are in a meter okay
oh [ __ ] yeah cuz Brian todos Brian it'll
check me yeah yes that was nowhere to go
Brian is there anywhere to park he goes
and you said it like this
nope yeah and then we get here and I'm
like there's the is a private parts
ability for gas never Park there's not
too much time the gate you just have too
much
I'm back down lazy right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue good what's
gonna happen what are you gonna do use
some of that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]